we got a new number now if you want to
call in we got a Google Voice number
let's get to some of those advice
questions right now how about that here
we have one of them right here this is
from Gabriel hey mr. feyo Vaughn my name
is Gabriel big fan of podcast and listen
to every one but I can't do all but uh
just so you post on Instagram and I got
a question for you
you ever had a hamster go south on you
like through all your years is that like
you're pretty got an expertise and
handle them hamsters they seem like
fuzzy furry animals and that's why
people want to buy them but you ever
have a hand should go ballistic on you
like an H go be you know [ __ ] goes south
you never know what's gonna happen
forget sorry about it I love to hear it
but anyways even if I don't hear about
it I'll still be listening my name is
Gabriel just moved to LA from Hawaii and
a man keep up the good work okay all
right Gabriel um if I had a hamster that
win that went crazy yeah some of you
guys know or don't know that I grew up
in a hamster breeding area you just work
at this place Bertram was one of my
first jobs they would sell hamsters and
ground game you know small I mean some
people pushed it as exotic meats
it was pets it was everything you know
bait you know just small animals guineas
HAMP's G pigs rats mice nutria and I
remember now one thing if you don't know
this about hamsters hamsters will if the
a lot of times birthing makes the
mothers very nervous and they will it's
kind of a bummer to say but they'll eat
their young that will get rid of their
young I mean they're basically they're
the Casey Anthony of small ground game
and this one time we had we had a
hamster that you know had some children
this lady this lady hamster had some
children knocked off her own children
you know just straight I've got super
Italian on them and then started killing
other hamsters children and that I've
never seen before and they had a dude
that worked at the hamster place who was
like I'm gonna take care of him and I
thought you know he'd poison him or
something but he he took him and shot
him in the head dude
you know and I hate to say that you know
I've had some issues with animals
accidentally you know killed that deer
with that lawnmower when I was working
on a soybean and cotton farm and that's
still haunts me man
still haunts me dude if you have not
been through and we've all got our own
little Viet Nam's and that was one for
me man just driving this you know six
eight foot grass and oh and you just
hear that
you hear band me go BAM me go down BAM
to go down but anyway yeah this hamster
got rogue and it was just killing local
hamster children and this dude I thought
you poison it or something but then
wouldn't who doesn't shoot a hamster in
the head bro you know I'm saying this
dude is straight up I mean that's that's
intense man that's really really intense
you know I feel like that's like I don't
even know what that is that's
unnecessary for sure you know do
something poison it do something but but
yeah this guy took it outside and shot
it so I guess Gabriel that would be your
answer man that's one of the only times
I have my own hamster go beyond me I had
a H go B but I mean they'll bite you
weld it and the hamsters we're getting
nowadays Gabriel I can't even tell you
if they're safe or not because a lot of
these hamsters they're from Russia if
you look at them they're angry they're
small they're meek they look at
premature
babies they're red-eyed red-handed just
already look real real scattered like
they're alcoholics or you know maybe in
cocaine Anonymous meetings they look
like hamsters you would meet in a place
like that
so I'm concerned about the you know the
the ground game that that's currently
coming through America because a lot of
that market went abroad a lot of that
market went to Russia so who knows maybe
Trump will bring some of that abroad
back back to the u.s. we'll see thank
you guys for checking out this clip and
if you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz this is alarming